Keagan starts off this hour in
indianapolis hi Keegan how are you
better than I deserve Dave how about you
just the same sir how can I help
well I've got a quick question about
student loans and the payback of them
recently married and my wife
I got herself into some student loan
trouble and when we got married were
going through the counseling she thought
she had twenty to thirty thousand but
wasn't real sure because her parents
weren't real transparent with lungs so
we got married in January and we've been
hitting her part which I found out was
thirty five thousand at about twenty
five hundred a month and just the other
day I found out that her parents did the
Parent PLUS or another fifty thousand
and they're wanting us to pay back pay
that back too and I'm just looking for
the direction that you would go so um
this family does a crummy job of
communicating and when the brain comes
up in counseling and she goes oh I think
I've got some student loans and then the
parents aren't real forthcoming that's
when we're going to have a cup of coffee
before the marriage goes forward and mom
and dad are going to come clean and be
forthcoming you let this happen to you I
did my my life is Rich Dad Poor Dad in a
book how old are you twenty-five that's
well put I like that good line okay so
as you understand it um does your wife
feel like because I'm a hundred percent
sure right now that nothing is written
down does your wife feel like that she
promised to pay the loans that her
parents were taking out to send her to
school
did she make that promise at the time
that she was going to school to them
there was no promise in it was such bad
organization and communication that she
thought there was
chance they would be paying for half or
all of the part that she had and some of
them that's what they need to do okay
because they didn't communicate Parent
PLUS loans your wife does not have her
name on them
the parents are Ronny okay and they just
borrowed fifty thousand bucks to send
their kid to schools what they did now
if you guys choose to pay some of that
that is a gift that's just you being
nice and so what I would do is I think
the four of you need to sit down and
really have a real clear conversation
and she how does your wife do when she's
communicating with her parents is she
intimidated Percy what is she
intimidated
I think a little bit and it's ever been
real open is what it should be about
honesty yes I think it needs to get real
open real fast and grab a yellow pad and
scribble down what we've agreed to and
everyone initial it and ate it not as a
contract but just because these people
don't have good memories I would you
approach it if say they make a very good
amount of money but they claim that this
is going to push them over the hole
under bankruptcy I don't think this is
going to push them over the hole into
bankruptcy if they make a good amount of
money I think others have done has done
that so that so now they're
guilt-tripping yeah okay so what is your
household income I can buy and we bring
how about eighty okay well what I would
do if I were in your shoes is I would
sit down with them the four of you and
very kindly and very gently we don't
want to destroy a relationship this is a
her parent you want to continue to have
a relationship with them if at all
possible and just say look you guys have
done a really all three of you you've
done a really bad job with this and you
look at you kind of got to be mediator
almost you look at your wife and go now
you told me that you didn't have any
idea that you were supposed to pay all
of this it wasn't clear to you at the
time right and she says yes then you go
did you guys tell her that she was
responsible or did you just
think she was going to know this by
osmosis and then they're going to go
well we didn't really talk about it
because we won't really talk about
anything and you go okay then
technically you know she didn't make you
a promise and there's two different
issues okay number one there's a legal
issue the legal issue is uo0 she's not
oh she's not on the debt you understand
that right
absolutely it has the only issue here
the only issue is is there a handshake
promise that your wife made that you
need to help her keep because you
married into that and to the extent and
my guess is you're probably going to do
something towards this loan as a matter
of a peace offering in this mess and the
way I would do that is I would say when
we finish getting out of debt then we
will pay you you know twenty thousand
dollars of this 50 or you know because
there's a misunderstanding and we want
to be kind and we want to go forward but
we're not going to pay at all that would
be something I would do if you want to
pay nothing if you want to pay nothing
you can but you're going to have trouble
with the relationship yeah and less long
lines of what I was thinking buy this
doesn't know how to learn it because I
feel like they need to participate in
the pain because of the lack of clarity
research me yeah the lack of clarity I
think you're exactly on it Keegan and in
a sense you can just say listen I you
know I wasn't here when all this was
done so you can kind of step back and
play mediator like you were trying to
work this out between them like you were
a counselor or something and then didn't
come to an agreement and go well you
know I think you point your wife I think
you should probably pay some of this and
so maybe you ought to pay twenty
thousand and they ought to pay thirty
thousand what is their household income
mmm I'm gonna I'm gonna guess and say
it's somewhere in the threes yeah so the
maximum I'm going to do is twenty the
minimum amount the minimum is zero
obviously and I'm not going to do that
until you're completely debt free of all
your personal debts that the two of you
have in your names
okay and then only then if you want to
do some towards this lack of clarity you
can and then you're going to run into
lack of clarity again
like what time you're getting there for
Thanksgiving Day yeah just be ready it's
going to be a pattern but just just be
happy and kind and you know they're
obviously out of control with money
they've tried to out-earn their
stupidity and maybe this can be a chance
for them to turn their life around but
if they're making 300k they're likely
not bankrupt and for sure 50k Parent
PLUS loans not putting them over the top
for bankruptcy if they're you know if
they're bankrupt if they're bankrupt is
because they've got millions of dollars
and debt on something else and not
because a $50,000 loan when you could
make 300 so I'm not I'm not buying that
guilt trip you have to sell that ticket
to somebody else open phones this our
life on the radio that's what we call it
around here it's work that matters
changing people's lives with this
information this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey you guys Rachael Cruz here hope
you're enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and
did you know that I have my very own
YouTube channel yes that's right kind of
better than
I'm kidding I'm kidding so subscribe and
there's lots of videos about life and
money so while you're at it if you want
to check out a video then you can check
out how to do a monthly budget it's one
of the best videos out there
you